it'll be okay
anyone can make up any excuse about
cancelling a tour and i feel like he's
just being straight up about it and i
also think that more artists need to be
open about their mental health to make
sure that they're doing okay as a person
too he's been my idol for forever and i
think i really really respect that i've
always been a nice girl
[Music]
clearly tate's taking it all in stride
coming off a string of successful
headlining tours herself in support of
her debut album i used to think i could
fly is that like having fans across the
world knowing your music
it was crazy because this was the first
year that i like actually like ever
really did a full tour us sold out uk
europe australia australia sold out in
four minutes which was
like wild it's just bizarre because you
don't ever think that people that far
away would actually hear you or know who
you are
[Music]
and it's not hard to see why tate's fans
are hoping she'll work with one of her
most famous friends in the future are we
going to get a collaboration with you
and olivia rodrigo
we make this happen
we've talked about writing a song
together for so long
honestly the problem is when you get in
the studio with your friends you get
nothing done i've always wanted to
collaborate with the weekend
i'm just a big he's a canadian i know
right right big fan of him yes that
would be super cool or like post malone